this smells interesting do you think
it's good Oh
mmm the texture is a little bit throwing
me off today we're gonna be guessing
which taco is the vegan taco I'm a
meat-eater my thoughts on vegan food I'm
glad it exists for people trying to
avoid meat I'm not one of those people
so I don't go for vegan food
we're both Filipino mm-hmm I'm sure
there are a lot of Filipino vegans and
vegetarians but it's really hard to be
one everything includes meat even our
vegetarian options the dipping sauce is
made of a shrimp I have been trying to
avoid meat but I have tried a couple of
vegan options and I've been into it
we'll see what happens today
I'm glad that there are new options
that's you a little bit more healthier
compared to like other meat options I am
NOT a vegetarian or vegan I'll still try
and be healthy in that way and get like
substitutes I'm into the vegan movement
there's no good reason for me to not be
vegan and I recognize that as a meat
lover you're just not gonna do it
I'm just not today you know maybe
today's the day I change my mind
let's just say I get the ethical reasons
for being vegan vegetarian
however I've also thought that if there
was a way to like clone me ethically so
technically it's vegan or vegetarian I
would totally do that I'm here for
veganism I'm here to love the planet we
shall probably not be eating as much
meat as we are but I also sometimes
can't help myself I can't not say no to
Korean barbecue or like any other
[ __ ] that have meat I've never had
vegan tacos strictly make taco lady oh
yeah yes love tacos bring it back oh
yeah I don't believe I've ever had a
vegan taco but I'm not opposed shame
ha okay Oh
smells like meat smells good it smells
like chicken maybe oh they're babies wow
these are very small I'm definitely
gonna save the other one in case I get
confused for later this is good I don't
know if I'm getting the texture of meat
though it doesn't taste like it tastes
like beans and cheese I can't taste the
meat maybe it's just in there somewhere
it's like mostly on the bottom so I'm
just flipping over and it's a little
gooey beans but I'm like biting into
like cubes of meat this is way harder
than I thought it was gonna be I do
think there's something else in here I'm
not sure if it's an avocado or some
other things well I'm gonna taste the
meat yeah the smell is there the taste
is there just the texture is a little
bit throwing me off alright I found who
enjoys the meat now yeah
the way it feels in my mouth feels like
a meat cube yeah I can feel like the
texture I found it among to the other
stuff in the taco I'm trying to lick
just the innards I was feeling around
for it
mm-hmm and then the texture is like yeah
but stringy and yeah yeah you know that
the texture of meat whenever you like
bite into it I like it
so that's why I'm gonna say I think it's
me mm-hmm I would say that this is neat
I'm gonna stick with my first thought
and say it's vegan
this is lettuce this has stuff on top
miss smells interesting it's good on
corn tortilla over here you can tell
would suggest from touching it
Wow taco expert this tastes like a
almost like a Baja Fresh top this is a
fish pop I can't tell there's cabbage on
it
people put cabbage on fish tacos this is
not a fish taco feel like it's fish yeah
so meat fish meats maybe it's trying to
be fish I'm not really sure what's going
on to be honest yeah I bite into it it's
like very chewy
it's like synonymous to fish chewy it
kind of has the texture of chicken just
feel like fish to me I think you're
right like fried fish I think it's
trying to be fish but it's not so I
think it's a medium check it out and
just eat what's in it like you know how
fish like a white fish there's like
layers of meat I would say that it's not
a meat substitute it would be an actual
plant just tastes good to me I think
it's fine there's a lot of good spices
happening but without that I don't know
if I would be crazy about it yeah this
is good do you think it's good either
that's good yeah right now my guess is
fish so me right now my guess is vegan I
don't know what anything tastes like
anymore I'm so confused right now I'm
thinking that this taco has fish so I'm
gonna say that it has I show right now
I'm leaning towards no I think this
might be the what kind of shell is
happening here this feels like also corn
mm-hmm the texture for some reason makes
me think that this might be of the
Oh mmm this has to be pork or faked pork
right mm-hmm pork is my favorite but
aftertaste is very interesting it's not
like anything that I've actually ever
tasted like I would feel like this is
the vegan one because of how much she's
eating there is this one I feel like has
a lot of marinate vegan substitutes they
really try and marinate it so that you
have more flavor because like it doesn't
feel like any meat doesn't taste like me
and doing like a pulled pork would be
easier to do with something like
jackfruit I have tried the impossible
burgers and the the texture is very
close to the impossible burgers imagine
how long it would take you to chew into
pulled pork either this is really good
pulled pork or or it's not beef at all
here I didn't disintegrates in my mouth
any mass like meat wouldn't do that
the texture is almost like a corn beefy
texture yeah yeah I also think this is
vegan but I've said that everything is
vegan so now I'm questioning all of my
answers it doesn't taste like it's vegan
but the texture and knowing what an
impossible burger feels like in my mouth
is what makes me think it's me I want to
say this taco is vegan I think this is
the vegan taco as well if this is
actually vegan I'd be jazzed
cuz it's tastes amazing this is really
good this is the best taco I think our
number one choice for the vegan taco is
the third option but the second one was
really close
yeah I'd say second one is really close
but I feel like the second one is
seafood so after careful deliberation I
think number three is vegan and number
three is vegan final answer the third
one is the vegans
oh well you convinced me that's very
good I was like I don't know what this
is this foot to be fish Wow we were so
close we thought that was a second like
option so this is number two Oh what Oh
interesting now knowing that a lot of
vegan substitutes were try to appease
didn't
our guess wasn't based on the taste
alone it was also a prior college yeah
yeah that felt like a fish I'm so glad I
like the meat one a lot where did you
guys get I don't think it really
necessarily changes the way I look at
vegan foods out by the the vegan option
if this is a vegan restaurant and these
are my options
I would definitely order it and I
wouldn't have a problem with it but I
would say if there was a meat option I
would probably prefer it I was really
wanting that to be the video one because
then my life would be different can you
guys just make this vegan because of our
culture I will say that I don't think I
can be 100% vegan because I get serious
FOMO and I don't want to be left out
Filipino parties yeah I gotta have my my
lip yeah I'm definitely thinking of
switching up my diet and becoming
vegetarian and something like this could
push me over the edge like I was just so
good because I'm the better person
honestly wait let's go find the
jackfruit taco maybe that will change
your mind
[Music]